my next guest right here on the Rich
Eisen show he's a guy who I first heard
be very honest with you Eric Stonestreet
of Modern Family big k-state guy he's
like look out for this guy in Seattle
when they drafted him before the draft
he told me look out for him
Seahawks drafted him and he has been
stellar absolutely stellar in now his
fifth season with the Seahawks he's got
a debut collection of original poetry
that's available wherever books are sold
available starting today called
reflection Tyler Lockett joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Tyler
I'm doing great
well uh five and one Tyler I mean what
has it been like so far first six weeks
of the season football I think we've
been playing phenomenal I think the
biggest thing is we know that we're not
even near our best the way that we
practice is the way that we're trying to
play on the field and I think anybody
starting to see it we've been in a whole
lot of close games which fear the
ability to find out how Google is going
to be able to stay poised and how to
come out with those victories and I
think those are the things that we've
been doing and it just kind of shows
that the way that we work the way that
we connect on the field and off the
field is really fun on the field well
how have you connected with Russell
Wilson walk me through this relationship
when you're playing in a league or when
you're playing football in general you
just gotta understand who your
quarterback years you got to understand
every aspect that he possesses and
everything that he does great and so for
me like even when I'm working out in the
offseason or even when I'm getting ready
for camp I'm putting myself in the
situation to do the things that I know
that Russell can do and so I might not
do the same stuff they're receivers
doing the offseason and that's okay
because I know my quarterback so when we
get into routines and we get into camp
practices and stuff like that I already
you know have that connection with them
because I know what he's doing I know
what he's looking for on certain types
of plays and it just helps that I could
put myself in position to stay alive
whenever you use me well that's a
perfect way to put a Tyler because that
was a question I wanted to ask you ton
of locker you're on the Rich Eisen show
you here's so many times that it's
difficult for receivers to keep running
routes or keep running around or keep a
play alive with a quarterback that runs
or scrambles as much as Russell Wilson
does and that play in the corner of the
endzone against the Los Angeles Rams a
couple of Thursday nights ago where
where Wilson just kept a play alive
throwing a ball against the grain of his
body going seemingly a little bit
backwards as well to find you and a
sliver of the endzone I gave up on the
play
I mean walked me through that one Tyler
yeah I mean a great job being able to
cover the whole play up and well you got
a quarterback like Russell look at the
players never over and so when he
started spreading it to the left luckily
I was over here on the left side and the
DB jersey you know his back was turning
to Russell and so it was never cease
that he might give us a chance to just
throw it up in the air and you know he
makes a lot of those visual type of
throws even though he might not actually
practice on this so the way that he
threw it he do it to where only I can
really catch it so I had to kind of feel
my guy off you know a lot of times I'm
not gonna just try to go jump ball with
everybody so I feel myself off from the
defender so we're only I can make a play
on the ball so either I drop it or I
don't and you know luckily I'm sure
enough to still keep my feet here that's
why I'm trying to reach out for the ball
you know and and this past week Tyler
against the Browns after the game
Russell Wilson and a crucial third
quarter drive said his helmet went out
did you know that at the time no I mean
because everybody found in their own
bias they're in their own mode when the
game is coming on but so as he's calling
plays you're just assuming it's coming
in he didn't say at one point hey I've
got nothing let's let me let me handle
it here he never voiced that in a natl I
mean you know Russ might see something
and he starts kind of like all this
stuff if we do quick game or whatever
the case is you have a great
relationships where they understand like
each other and they know kind of like
the film of the game and how to flow is
going
and so they based up off of that so
regardless of you know who's doing what
we trust a he's gonna put us in the best
position possible and that just comes
with the type of relationship so what we
went out there we just stayed true to
the game plan
to a lot of things and because the
helmet or the voice they might have went
out in the third quarter or if that was
the case we already had a feel of what
they do so we knew what plays to put it
in that put it in a group
well somebody pants tyler lockett the
Seattle Seahawks here in the Rich Eisen
show again we'll talk about his new
debut collection of original poetry
called reflection that's available where
books are sold today so many fans are
talking about the officiating right now
are you guys talking about NFL
officiating in your locker room no not
really I know a lot of people been
talking about is his last game but
honestly
yesterday's game but I really watch the
game it's kind of preparing myself to
get ready for was Tillman today but
obviously you know I kind of heard about
a lot of the stuff that's happened then
everybody has their own opinions about
it and stuff and you know I think my
thing is the game is you know always
gonna be based off the human error and
you know there's gonna be a lot of great
decisions made a lot of a lot of good
calls me let me say there there'll be a
lot of bad calls made but at the end of
the day you know it's always been like
that and that's kind of what makes the
game great you know when you look at
basketball when you look at football I
think you know sometimes it hurts in
pivotal moments you know because human
error becomes magnified specially a
playoff that's always kind of like in
some situations you know it works out
and other situations it does it but I
just think it's hard to try to figure
out ways to remove human error because
if you do that then every player is
gonna be refused because there's always
gonna be a foul you know I've asked
about it's always going to be a flag in
football and so is it you know kind of
trying to pick which moment can we allow
in your area to be right it will be
allow him there to be wrong so would you
be in favor of scrapping instant replay
for pass interference Tyler I mean
honestly I don't really think that you
know that's really been a big deal you
know I think I haven't really watched a
lot of other games but I think they've
been doing a good job and calling had it
going back and reviewing it but you know
like there's times where you know people
they want to see a good game and the
team might be in a really good flow you
know at a game and
I'll say you know we got to keep going
to review stuff to make sure that we got
it right I don't think that there's
anything that we could ever do to make
sure everything is right I just think
sometimes you just got to rely on you
know everybody that's out there and they
just kind of make a decision and go with
it but whatever decision they go with it
it's not gonna work out for what P are
you saying that because you actually
were involved in one of those rare
instances where a pass interference was
went successfully challenged Tyler why
me yeah but when we played the rounds we
challenged it and it didn't work out in
our favor and knows I just think like I
said I just think every day every single
play you could call holding you know
every single play you can call like a
legal hand you know illegal touching
because you know a DP can't touch a
receiver at the five yards you know like
there's a lot of things that you could
call every single play but that doesn't
mean that every you know every penalty
should be called and you know I'm not a
ref and you know I know that they have a
lot to look at they told us all the
things that they have to look at and
stuff during the whole entire game and
so you know I mean it's just a whole new
situation our position to be put in
because no matter what happened all I
can appeal if it's not called the way
that it should be called but I mean
that's just kind of how it like is Tyler
Lockett joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show team leader in receptions and
receiving yards this season for a
quarterback that is playing MVP football
Tyler Lockett here in the Rich Eisen
show why why write some poetry and put
it in a book and put so much personal
information about yourself out there
Tyler not me personally you know I love
writing poetry spoken word poetry is
something that I've done since I was a
senior in high school and you know the
reason why I love it so much because we
have a conversation with somebody
everybody wants to be able to put their
opinions out there so everybody goes
back and forth with arguing and stuff
like that and you never get your point
across but the thing about smoking
whatever it is I want to go up there
before everybody literally has to sit
there and listen and no choice but to
understand your thoughts understand
where you coming
how you feel and the truth is you know
spoken word poetry is kind of like just
write down your thoughts in a journal it
doesn't even have to lie you can make it
be whatever you want it to be and doing
that allows you to be more free allows
you to be able to play more and for me
like I use it for my faith and I use it
to bring hope and inspiration and just
talk about real-life situations that
people are scared to talk about but you
know behind closed doors these are
things that they're dealing with every
single day and so yeah it might be some
stuff in there that's about me some
stuff in there that's about people that
I know that's going through stuff and
instead of me saying if people you know
I put myself in that position because
the best way to help somebody is not
pointing the finger and talking about
somebody else but just being able to
share your own scars and your own
experiences and that way if they relate
then it makes it all the more better so
what's the most difficult thing that you
you're proud of sharing in this book
yeah that for you that you said you know
what I'm gonna put it out there I think
the best thing that I shared was um you
know I got a poem in there called the
monster created and there was nothing in
his life that I can honestly say that
could defeat me or that I was allowed to
put myself in a position to remove me
from the purpose that I believe I was
cause doing his life and what I started
realizing was my own imagination became
the monster because you know when you
start having a little bit of anxiety and
all these different types of things it
starts to kind of bother you and now you
start putting yourself in a place where
you created the very monster that you
defeat you in his life and so I've
talked about that I talked about how the
monster tried to control me and it was
like the very strength they got me to
the place that got me was the was the
very thing that I couldn't lean on
anymore and a weaknesses I never paid
attention to in life because I was
always focusing on my strengths those
were the things that I had to hold on to
and so you know when you deal with
traumas and you're strong-minded that's
the worst thing that could happen to
somebody because literally you
overanalyze you literally go through the
whole story over and over and over you
can really
feel as if you know the reason why it
happened when the truth is it's already
right in front of you you just keep over
analyzing the whole situation and now
you can't get out of your head so now
it's like you're allowing yourself to be
the very monsters that could defeat you
and so I learned how to beat that and I
think that's one of the best things and
I can talk about cuz you know everybody
talks about mental health they talk
about all you think that bothers them
that make them the way that they are and
the thing is wants you to understand
your triggers and you understand why
things make you act or become the way
that you are then that monster is
already defeated and there's nothing
else I could teach you because you know
yourself and that's all in one poem yeah
it's amazing
that's amazing man good for you tyler
lockett reflection available starting
today debut collection of original
poetry available wherever books are sold
so you guys talking superbowl openly
flat out now we talking Baltimore right
now reason we focus on one game at a
time but the best thing about the way
that teachers every game is a Super Bowl
so that way you know if you make it
doesn't become a surprise
you know everybody when you get to the
playoffs people try to go hard you know
they make the game more serious but this
is how the game should be every single
game and that's how we that's how we
approach it when you approach every game
like a Super Bowl you know approaches if
it's the last image you ever play you
gotta wait eight more months until you
can play again and just being able to
have that pice that allows us to do
whatever it is that we need to do we put
our bodies on the line we sacrifice what
we need to sacrifice in order to help
but help our guys win and that's what
it's all about and I think when you
watch our games that's what you see you
see guys out there having fun you see
guys out there cheering one another on
you see the relationships that we have
on and off the field and that's what
allows us to build this type of like
advantage over teams because it does
just football we're not worried about
all the stuff that comes with it we're
not worried about all that type of stuff
but we have a tight-knit group that you
know open it up to each other and that's
what allows us to really be
well when you have a minute with Pete
Carroll but just uh you know ask him
about coach Harbaugh of the Ravens
brother and the battles they used to
have in college and it's always
interesting when a Harbaugh gets
together with Pete Carroll he'll tell
you a couple stories if you don't know
them already you know they're make a
great poem it'll make a great poem and
it'll be called what's your deal bro
that's what it'll be called okay it's
called what's your deal bro tell them
that you want to write a poem about that
and for him to fill in the information
Tyler I just want to leave you with that
hey congratulations on this I can't wait
to read some of it and I hope this is
the first of many times that we have a
conversation on the show yes sir well
let me know what you think once you read
some of it I will absolutely
thanks again Tyler well I'll be in touch
you got it that's Tyler Lockett at TD
Lockett with two T's 12 on both Twitter
and Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 unto
ret TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app